he acts like a gay guy to get close to
this girl on the on the cruise ship well
I've done that before but I've never
watched that movie okay well
[Music]
so the director of the Jurassic World
movies
like all three of them James Cameron not
Colin trevorrow oh travaro he thinks
that the movies should have probably
stopped after the original Steven
Spielberg film he shouldn't have made
any films you know why because these are
the same
I mean that's a the First new one from
the Chris Pratt version I liked it but I
was like oh these are the same beats as
the first dressing you liked it you
liked this most recent one I like you
know what I was watching on peacock yeah
so I was like for a free movie this is
fine oh it's free I mean Dominion the
third one yeah yeah but the first but
the first Jurassic Park I saw in
theaters and I was like look I think you
go you go see those movies in theater
just because you look at all the cool
dinosaurs and that's it that's all but
it's the same time for real I feel like
yeah the [ __ ] Raptor scene in the
kitchen I was like dude I've seen this
before I saw the first one and I liked
it because I had a head injury thank you
exactly that's that's how I operate
daily anyway so what a review yeah it
was a review
um what did you like about the first one
all of it I [ __ ] thought that movie
was garbage you didn't like how he was
talking to the Raptors and he's like
come here girl you know come here you
know what's funny about that movie I saw
that movie you guys know Taryn Terence
Southern yeah yeah I saw the movie with
Taryn is me and Nikki and Taryn and like
we saw that movie and we're all we all
walked out of that [ __ ] movie with
those duels that's why you didn't give
it a chance dude oh is that what it is
yeah so you didn't even see the T-rex
fight at the end I walked out two
minutes before the end oh remind me what
what it was uh what was the critic
response to this one it was probably
terrible it's a cash grab you watch
something like oh these are just scams
to be fair please I um I didn't walk in
expecting another Spielberg Innovative
thing that's true I was just like I like
dinosaurs and I like good [ __ ]
Graphics I like the CGI in it so I think
the first one gave me enough of that and
it checked those two boxes enough I was
in entertain even though it's a bad
movie yeah I was able to be entertained
okay the second and third movie the
second movie was terrible third movie I
couldn't finish even though it was free
on HBO yeah and I like dinosaurs is that
bad is that odd I didn't finish I didn't
finish Dominion either I saw the first
like 20 minutes and I was like oh that's
cool I don't think you could follow
Steven Spielberg though yeah you can't
it's just they just leave it to rest
just leave it yeah and that [ __ ] was
like Innovative during that time plus
they were using like animatronics and
[ __ ] that's always gonna be way sicker
than [ __ ] CGI do they got John
Williams on the soundtrack they didn't
they just kept using this yeah they were
using similar tones it's not magic that
Steven Spielberg John Williams team you
can't beat that that's the only thing
that let the first thing be tight
actually yeah is when you see the whole
world and the music they like they like
stumble across across the old Jurassic
Park and then once they see like the
banner and stuff like that the little
[ __ ] tune the Jeep yeah so so that
was cool and I think that's why it was
likable but in the most recent one when
they bring in the old cast and stuff
it's so cheesy Nostalgia right Nostalgia
is how they they get you now they get
you with that stall do they get you hard
they get you nice and hard and then
you're ready to [ __ ] and then you find
out that nobody's coming to [ __ ] you or
blow you or anything
like it's all like oh that's a movie
review it's just a scam it's all scam
they got me all the way full hard and
then like there's nothing gonna cool
with the Fast and Furious franchise oh
don't talk [ __ ] on that though you
better be careful
look at how I'm dressed
take the franchise I hated the last the
last the last one was terrible oh is
that the one where the rock breaks out
of his [ __ ] his cast yeah the rock
wasn't in the last one go to space no
yeah oh I didn't see it that's the one
with the uh respectfully I only liked I
didn't like any of that movie until they
went to space now I'm sorry because you
like spaces
yeah I saw that and I was like all right
I like seeing ludicrous creatine but
it's like can you make it like look I
get it like it's you're you're making a
big scene out of it but it's like is
there a way we can make this a little
less corny you know what I mean I think
they played into the corny well and then
it went way too crazy during like Hops
and Shop post era yeah I was a child was
my favorite Papa John's the greatest
movie ever made okay Robin shot should
be a Criterion when they when they go
back to the motherland with all the
[ __ ] Tongans and the Samoans did
Russia was crazy you know that's hot
jobs
huh you didn't like Creed I did like
Creed I didn't like Creed either I
couldn't get I do got created you do
like Creed I thought Creeds suck dick
whoa on Ice I thought it was bad me too
I couldn't get through it the the movie
opens Creed is already really good at
fighting oh cool where's should be
really hard like fighting these
underground circuits no one knows who he
is yeah I like Southpaw Southpaw was
good that was a good boxing movie I'm
only bringing Creed up because I feel
like it was that similar type of feeling
which I feel like so many franchises are
redoing right same thing you're bringing
like the Our Generation older generation
cast into the story and then making it
work with the newer generation you know
what I'm saying that's what reboots are
for right yeah but like some of them
aren't done well like the Karate Kid so
patronizing
it just sounds that way I didn't mean
that like that you just handed Anthony
he's Quest Crew I'm used to it that way
I didn't mean it that way to you I just
I just bet that's why reboots kind of
get a pass because it's it's just to
cash in from the next cash crap yeah
because they won't buy it no it's my
Karate Kid [ __ ] analogy what about
Karate Kid I didn't see that are you
talking about the second one with the
mean Asian guy yeah with Jaden and
Jackie's hands I didn't see it no but
that's like a reboot as well but that's
not like what about when Sylvester
Stallone showed up in Creed
and you're using the same people that
like we fell in love with and you're
trying to make that work in the new
story right but that's what Jurassic
Park does with this latest one but it
was terrible yeah but Goldblum did was
he like hesitant and stuff
because that's what I like
yeah he's like oh
um yeah I don't know thank you life
finds a way yeah okay good that was
really good I have a gold Bloom at
Independence Day though follow you but
hey Goblin Independence the best
but Jeff Goldblum in the Billy Studio
though a Goldblum in Death Wish one you
haven't seen it he's he plays a he plays
a
oh
boy I remember that now holy [ __ ] I
remember that now I was like when is the
first movie released he's just a villain
he's just a throwaway bad guy I gotta
practice that with a Jughead Crown I
remember that
like remade like some for modern era
Death Wish was Bruce Willis I'm kidding
there's probably not a good example you
mean like of one like one that actually
did well that that pleased well it
depends how far back you're looking
because Nutty Professor is good and how
much and how much they can read Assault
on Precinct 13 with Ethan Hawke I
thought was [ __ ] sick but a lot of
people hate that movie I enjoyed that
movie deep cut how did you guys feel
about Jumanji it was cool it was all
right it's cool to watch an airplane
because they they also brought back an
old actor in that one too right the kid
or whatever I don't even remember him it
was all right it's cool to watch when
I'm trapped somewhere and I can't go
yeah and I have nothing else
because there are certain movies that
like work pretty well in certain
situations like one when you're on an
airplane some movies are so forgiving
yeah like I just watch some brainless
content yeah and you're like this is
cool you know but when I watch this to
go see the theater that's that's what I
thought about boat trip I think I saw in
a really weird state of mind and I liked
it everybody [ __ ] [ __ ]
um with Walter Matthau right well no
boat trip is the one with Cuba Gooding
Jr oh my bad do you remember that no no
you didn't see that one where he's like
he acts like a gay guy to get close to
this girl on the on the cruise ship I've
done that before but I've never watched
that movie okay well it's apparently
objectively bad and I I thought it was
good
I was like out to sea oh okay this is a
Walter Matthau movie with Jack Lemmon
and Walter mattha they were [ __ ]
hilarious together what are movies that
are so bad that they're good
I mean I guess the room would be the
champion of all have you guys ever the
room Ghost Rider bro super fast oh yeah
I've seen it it's the Fast and Furious
parody [ __ ] film it's so bad it's
pretty bad that it's good it's pretty
[ __ ] terrible it's like this I think
here's a scene from it there's like a
boot like Vin Diesel I think and then
he's racing uh someone else because
they're trying to re redo the first fast
and furious scene and I think like in
the middle of like shifting gears
because he's going faster and faster
when someone else hits NOS randomly
there's like shaving cream on his head
and he's like
she's like shaving his head and he's
like goes to the third gear like that's
the type of movie why do they do that
yeah but it's so bad it's good for you
it's one of those that's so bad it's so
funny the more you watch it the better
it gets and the more you go hey you
gotta see this then the just it becomes
like this spectacle do you think that
these guys just watch airplane with
cross eyes
yeah and they're like where I know oh
that's good this is good yeah because we
have some shaving cream on his head yeah
most most dance movies are so bad
they're good most dance moves like what
there's one some of them try to be good
that they're so bad yeah there's one
that's the champion of all it's called
it's called dancing it's on that's a
great title not so many dance words that
one sound like that one just just the
ADR alone is so bad that like it sounds
like everything's a narration in
people's minds because the way they
recorded it's like without any
atmosphere so everyone sounds like
they're thinking their dialogue when
you're watching this movie at one minute
Mark where you're like it's on it oh
[ __ ] there was a movie on Showtime when
I was like a [ __ ] kid I was probably
like
12 or 11. it was called like the
kickboxing academy and it was about it
was kind of like the same premise of
best of the best but with kids and then
at the very end there's always a [ __ ]
karate tournament Winner Takes all or
whatever right the the bad guys they
lose and the bad Sensei at this like
giant tournament with a gang of people
he pulls out like a submachine gun with
like bandoliers and he starts shooting
in the sky and he's holding everyone
hostage it's so sad and this little boy
comes up and [ __ ] punches him in the
dick and it's like
he saves the day and I was like and I
used to watch this movie
every single [ __ ] time and I knew I
was I was like 12 or 11. I knew this
movie was dog [ __ ] but I just couldn't
stop watching it because I was like this
is great like I don't know what it is
but I just love this movie but dude
that's great so look up the kickboxing
academy I think that's what it's called
that's how it felt about Miami
Connection you ever seen that see all
these movies nobody has ever seen this
one's an 80s movie about a it's a rock
band a group of teenagers that are also
all black belts and they have to defeat
ninjas I already love it yeah this is
good that's way better I'm about to jump
into all their whole treatment all their
songs all their rock songs talk [ __ ] on
ninjas
you see all these movies get made right
and then we have what like [ __ ] four
scripts that we've been pitched around
pitched around town yeah someone paid to
have Vin Diesel shave his head in a
[ __ ] race car our scene and we can't
even get [ __ ] like 200 000 to shoot a
[ __ ] movie you gotta Finance it
yourself so great damn that's right
Stallone dude you know what Stallone
went through for Rocky right yeah like
he basically it was like he sold this
dog too right sold his dog he's like oh
I'm gonna saw my dog and then he's just
using that to pay bills and [ __ ] and
then he finally like sells Rocky and
they're like we don't want you to star
in it and he's like okay well then I
don't want to sell you Rocky and then he
had to negotiate with those guys but he
only got to sell Rocky because he went
in for an audition somewhere and he just
started cold talking to these guys after
he was like I'm not right for the part
but like you guys should check out my
movie Rocky and they actually listen
they actually read it and like it's it's
[ __ ] crazy wow that's tight it's
crazy amazing and then he actually got
to self-produce it he he started in it
he didn't even make like I don't think
he made like 20 grand off of it like the
initial run and then but in the points
later on he buys his dog back and then
gets sick points later on hey bought his
dog back at a [ __ ] loss did he really
yeah the guy sold it back to him for
more
that's wild I've Got The Leverage so I
looked up the movie The kickboxing
academy wow so I found it there's this
is because I wanted to look this up
before I told you guys about it in the
in the movie there's a a female love
interest and a male love interest right
in real life they're brother and sister
and they share a kiss on screen oh Mark
in the movie and they play each other's
love interest so that's why you should
watch this movie you're a weirdo dude
it's with Kyler lay she's [ __ ] sick
she kissed her brother in the movie
remember blank check blank check dude
that kid kisses the bank lady
he's like [ __ ] 12 years old he's got
to be goddamn 11 and a half maybe he's
13 in September though maybe but dude
the bank lady is dead look up the
[ __ ] fun fact in that movie do you
guys remember the chick from Dumb and
Dumber like oh you remember this movie
Manny from Scarface is in this movie see
which movie dude there's a lot of
conversation going on sorry his
kickboxing academy movie you guys
remember the the uh the chick from Dumb
and Dumber like the woman Swanson with
yeah who's with the henchman guy and
she's like what the [ __ ] yeah yeah she's
the bank lady in blank check oh no he
kisses an 11 year old kid in this movie
on the lips on the lip remember that
[ __ ] so this is just this is just
industry that's what kids wanted to see
technically and she tells him she's like
let me know when you're older after they
kiss I'm not kidding what the [ __ ]
that's why I think and then she goes I'm
Colonel John McBee everyone goes baby
[Music]